Jarry what does this mean for the media
landscape Gawker will continue to
operate Nick Denton has made that Pierre
that's correct yeah they're gonna
continue to publish as normal but
they've filed for bankruptcy protection
after losing this case against Hulk
Hogan and they also have their put
themselves up for sale and we know that
they already have one company that's
agreed to buy them Ziff Davis which has
been a magazine publisher for many years
our sources are telling us that the
offers for around a hundred million
dollars but that's not a final deal this
is going to go up for an auction there
can be higher bidders than that so you
know remains to be seen what happens and
who ends up with gawkers properties we
just got a statement from Nick Denton of
Gawker here saying quote we've been
forced by this litigation to give up our
long-standing independence but our
writers remain committed to telling the
true stories that underpin credibility
with our millions of readers with
stronger backing and disentangle from
litigation they can perform their vital
work on more platforms and in different
forms Emily Chang let me ask you about
the involvement here of Peter Thiel the
the venture capitalist the billionaire
venture capitalist reportedly who has
backed Hulk Hogan's legal costs here in
this case a lot of people have seen this
and raised a concern that if a
billionaire can do this it makes it very
difficult to cover billionaire without
fear of the kind of retribution the Nick
Denton Gawker have seen here David I did
speak with Peter Till's team today
they're not commenting right now however
it's been really fascinating to see
people in Silicon Valley taking sides on
this you have a lot of journalists who
are very angry you have even Jeff Bezos
the CEO of Amazon and owner now of the
Washington Post says that that Peter
Thiel is is basically digging a grave
for himself and should have had a
thicker skin on the other hand there are
a number of venture capitalists people
who by the way a Gawker has written some
not nice things about people like Chris
Sacca and Vinod Khosla who have come to
Peter Thiel's defense I actually sat
down with Vinod Khosla yesterday
legendary venture capitalist founder of
Sun Microsystems
he's been the target of a couple of
Gawker pieces and I said where do you
draw the line when it comes to freedom
of the press take a listen to what he
had to say the definition of what the
press is has
is very ambiguous now he's a bloomberg
journalist the same as a hustler
magazine journalist is a blog poster
individually a journalist the same way
there's you know what is the line to me
there's two things that matter anything
that goes without checks and balances is
going to go out of kilter and to a Nick
Dunne whom I'd say he needs checks and
balances and if a lawsuit supports that
if the facts weren't in favor of Hulk
Hogan
Peter Thiel would be irrelevant his
lawsuits would be around in fact Gawker
and Nick Denton did something to Hulk
Hogan
they created a legal case it's important
to use the law for checks and balances
interesting point they're well taken
that look a court found Gawker guilty of
doing something wrong here I did see
Nick Denton speak at code at the code
conference a couple of weeks ago and he
was definitely a bit more reflective he
didn't quite so go so far as to say he
had any regrets but did say that at
times the reports perhaps swayed a bit
towards more snarky than he would have
liked and yet still you know these are
stories that were put up on his web site
sure I just want to ask you here about
the degree to which clockers can be able
to mount the kind of appeal it says it
will obviously get some loans some money
from this bankruptcy but how difficult a
hill is that for them to have to climb
yeah I mean I think Nick Denton just put
out a statement today and he's saying
that you know look when we sell our
assets we're gonna have the financial
resources to continue to do the work
that we're proud of so yeah I mean this
is obviously not the outcome that Nick
Denton was hoping for but the statement
he put me just put out he seems very
optimistic about the future